It's great to welcome to the program today,
Ted Canova, who's an author practicing emersion
writing, as well as director of NY Use Arthur
L. Carter Journalism Institute.
I've actually recommended one or two of Ted's
books to my audience in the past.
Ted, I really appreciate your time.
Thanks for talking to me.
So there are a lot of people in my audience
who may not immediately know what we mean
by immersion writing and some of the work
that you've done in advance, sometimes for
years before you will write a book.
Certainly knew Jack where you actually became
a correctional officer in order to tell the
story of what that's like in coyotes.
You actually travel across the US Mexico border
with undocumented immigrants and and even
subsequently work with them in multiple places
in the United States.
So first, to just kind of frame it when you
start a project like this, what's the genesis
of an idea?
How do you think about your relationship to
the subject matter and start thinking about
how you'll carry the project out?
Sure.
I guess you could say my approach is to try
to go more in-depth than a regular journalist.
Can I look for a subject that matters to people?
Maybe it's mass incarceration.
Maybe it's immigration, undocumented immigration
or homelessness.
And I think, OK, what have journalists and
others been able to do to cast light on this
topic?
And what could I do if I were willing to spend
more time and get closer, get my hands dirty
if needed?
And often the answer has been, I try to go
beyond the sort of interview a journalist
does write, asking the five W's and all that
and spend time living with somebody else or
doing what they do.
So my first book is about railroad tramps,
and I was still an undergraduate in college
and rode the rails.
I met Mexicans while doing that and using
my high school Spanish, I realized they would
talk to me.
And in fact.
It seemed open to it and it seemed open to
me hanging out.
And that became my my second book called Coyotes,
which you mentioned.
And then, yeah, when I moved to New York from
Colorado.
Oh, gosh, 20 years ago, mass incarceration
was all over the news as it is again today.
And.
I thought, you know, there's got to be a way
to get closer to the subject than just.
You know, calling up people on the phone or
doing interviews and ended up applying for
a job, as in New York state corrections officer,
which took about three years to get.
And then I worked.
That worked at SingSing almost a year for
that book.
And the idea is, yeah, I get closer.
I'm not a standard journalist keeping my distance.
I'm I'm right in there.
And, you know, sometimes distance is good.
It lets you be a little more objective.
But I tend to get subjective.
I say, you know, I'm a I'm a CEO.
I'm scared of this situation or I'm a CEO.
The guys around me are angry, and today I
understand it.
I feel kind of angry myself.
And and so I try to take notes on what it
feels like to be there.
In the book, New Jack and also in some of
the research I did preparing for the interview.
You talk about the perception that could have
been the one that your your coworkers at SingSing
came away with when they learned about the
fact that you were researching and ultimately
wrote a book about your experience there,
that they might be mad at you.
They might not like the fact that you essentially,
I mean, to call it it's not a ruse in the
sense that you really did go through the training.
You really did work there.
You nobody knew you weren't treated differently
because there was this book coming at the
end of the experience, but that maybe you
took advantage in some way that is not OK
or that they would in some way be displeased
with the fact that you were there, not just
as a correctional officer, but also as a writer
for sure.
What was I mean.
Is there a fair critique to be made that you
were sort of using the resources of training
in order to end up writing a book, or do you
find that not to be a fair critique?
Well, you've asked a couple of questions.
That last one is, did I, you know, somehow
take advantage of the resources of the state
of New York just to, you know, just to be
able to write something about it?
And in fact, I stayed on the job longer than
the typical trainee does.
Most people drop out before I did and I stuck
with it.
So I think New York State got their value
from me as a good employee.
I got good job ratings.
I tried really hard to be a good corrections
officer and understand what that meant.
That's one of two projects which you could
call undercover, because I could not tell
people my full background or my real agenda,
which was to write something about this.
The other time I did that, I became a USDA
meat inspector at a beef plant in Nebraska.
And that was secretive, too.
And if you do something in a secretive way,
you are deceptive and deception is best avoided
in journalism.
But there are times when in order to do something
important, I think deception is warranted.
Not all journalists agree, but there was no
other way I could understand the life of an
officer, a guard at Sing Sing without doing
that job.
I had previously actually gotten an assignment
from The New Yorker to write about CEO's upstate
and then the state wouldn't let me go to work
with them.
They would let me visit a single prison once
for a short guided tour.
But this is a big deal.
It's Corrections is the second largest employer
in New York state or was when I was a CEO.
And how could how do you justify keeping the
public out?
So I felt justified in getting the job secretly.
And then, you know, every journalist faces
a moment of reckoning when the when what they've
written comes out or what they've produced
on video.
The subjects like it or they don't.
And they say it's true or they say that's
B.S.
It's not really different when you've done
something undercover people you write about
are still you.
They're going to say that's B.S. or they're
going to say, yeah, well, actually, that's
true.
And.
Far and away.
CEOs said that book is true.
You know, it's warts and all.
We don't look good in the whole thing.
But I got credit for doing the job myself
and and for telling the truth about it.
Most angry was the state of New York, which
put out a press release urging aggrieved employees
to sue me if if they felt I had injured them
somehow.
And I think the people who felt injured, whether
the state corrections bureaucrats, who's who
felt I'd snuck into their prisons and and
talked about it, which I wasn't supposed to
do.
One of the things in New Jack that comes out,
which I think couldn't possibly have come
out if you were just interviewing people,
is the sort of many sides of the prototypical
correctional officer in the sense that there
is often conflict about their views of the
system.
There's conflict about the views on even individual
inmates as some of the stories that you tell.
What else was only possible in the telling
of that story because you were immersed as
a correctional officer that by interviewing
people simply could not have been part of
the story.
I'm really happy you brought up that example,
because to me, that is what this approach
lets me do, is look at a big fat stereotype
like the guard as bruit or the guard as sadist
and think and ask out loud.
How much of that is true?
And and you're right.
I found in some cases.
Gosh.
That guy's pretty bad, but in lots of other
cases, in fact, in most cases what I found
was.
Human beings trying to keep something good
in themselves alive while being immersed in
this negative environment.
Day after day after day, like it's a crummy
job, it brings out the worst in them.
It brought out the worst in me.
My wife observed it, showed her my inner disciplinarian,
which I had actually never tried to cultivate.
But that's kind of what the job asked you
to do, is say no.
All day long to your fellow human beings.
So the to get to your question, more particularly
working at Sing Sing, put me in a group of
officers of color and there's no way I could
have learned the things I learned about their
lives.
Otherwise, I'm.
I remember the day I'm talking to the crew
I worked with in B Block.
It's this giant housing block, more than six
hundred prisoners.
We had like 15 minutes outside the mess hall
before we had to start frisking prisoners.
And a guy named Alcantara, who's Dominican
and lives near New York City.
Describe double parking outside his mom's
building.
Because she was moving and he had his minivan
and he ran inside her lobby to pick something
up.
And as he's running out, undercover officers
thinking he's part of a drug deal, tackle
them.
And I heard this, a version of this story
like six different times.
These are officers of color.
I work with who are being pulled over by police
on traffic stops or they're being stopped
by undercovers in Harlem because they are
people of color.
And that makes a big impression, you know.
And I wouldn't of been able to tell stories
like that had I not done the job myself.
One of the things that I took away from it
in hearing you describe in the book, kind
of your personality transformation as you
describe and your wife dealing with it, is
that maybe there really is more to this idea
that the focus on individuals in systems,
even now, like with the unrest and protests
that we are seeing, the focus on individuals
is relevant because people are people as individuals.
But we shouldn't ignore the effect that systems
have.
And that was a really big takeaway for me.
Yeah, the system makes you act a certain way.
Let's say you are a person convicted of a
crime who has had friends of different races.
You know, you're from a place where it was
cool making friends who who didn't look like
you.
Well, you're going to prison and that's that
stuff doesn't fly in a lot of prisons.
You have to stick with your own kind.
You know, prisons are racially polarized.
And then they're ideologically polarized and
they're organized by gang and and so prisoners,
inmates have to act a certain way.
And then so do officers.
Let's say I'm an officer who thinks it's OK
to have a conversation with a prisoner.
Like just, you know, I wish you did.
I mean, that was something you describe.
I thought, well, that's you.
That's a good idea.
Right?
That's how you manage people.
You talk to them.
There's a whole bunch of officers who who
think that's a terrible idea, that that you're
going to you're going to get a reputation
as the inmates friend.
Right.
A guy who won't uphold the rules.
And.
And in fact, there were some cases like that
where some officers were just too friendly.
And you think, well, what's what's that about?
Because a certain distance is appropriate.
But, yeah, you're in the system where your
uniform defines how you interact with other
people.
And and you're one of a group of people, whether
you're a prisoner or an officer, you're one
of a group.
And you have to act in accordance with the
standards of that group.
And gosh, when I see officers now standing
shoulder to shoulder to repel demonstrators,
I'm always thinking, OK, how many of them
are spoiling for a fight?
Because you can tell some of them are right.
You know, all of their hearts are beating.
Bump, bump, bump.
They're like, OK, is it?
When's it gonna start?
How long can I restrain myself?
What are who's going to stick up for me if
rock hits me in the head?
But then, you know, there's a whole bunch
of them who are like, oh my God.
Let me just get home in one piece and back
to my family and my my toddler and.
Right.
I, I didn't really sign up to be in a riot.
And but how is how are those people going
to act when.
When
it comes to violence, how will they?
Will they respond to their training with restraint?
Will they respond to their, you know, that
their ancient brain and start firing a weapon
or flailing with a gun?
The whole question of how you act when you're
a law enforcement officer and part of a group
that's under stress is superimportant and
matter so much today.
And, yeah, so that's that's kind of the thing
I wanted to find out about.
Let's pause the conversation there on our
podcast, but we'll have the full conversation
with Ted on our on our YouTube channel.